it's fine
thank you good evening everyone welcome
to
rochefort district council's remote
meeting of the executive
welcome to visiting members and also
welcome to
anyone watching this via the live stream
if i can go to agenda item one which is
apologies for
absence uh no apologies for absence have
been received
uh so uh and i think looking around uh
everyone is actually
here so thank you for that moving to
agenda item number two uh
non-members attending uh sonia would you
be kind enough to read out the
names of any non-members attending we've
got councillor dave sparing
councillor julie gooding and councillor
thank you for that um right turning now
to the
um minutes of the meeting
of the 8th of july
and they have been circulated uh
and uh can i ask if
those are agreed please members
great agreed thank you very much
those minutes are agreed
item number four which is to take uh
declarations of interest are there any
uh
declarations of interest from members
present
no i think uh that's a little return on
that
item number five is questions on notice
from
councillors and no questions have been
received members
which takes us to agenda item
six matters referred to the executive
reports
from other committees there are none
members
onto agenda item seven which is the
quarter one twenty twenty twenty one
financial
management and performance report uh
councillor simon smith portfolio holder
for
finance will now introduce a report
councillor smith
thank you very much chairman um a bit
more detail from me
this time and as you might expect
um i i think drama is the wrong word but
this is the
quarter representing april may and june
the the quarter which does reflect
lot lockdown so the purpose of the
report is to set out the forecast
revenue
and capital budget positions as of the
end of
quarter one 2021 the latest
revenue budget for 2021 is 10.38 million
changes to the original budget are due
to drawdowns from reserves which are
detailed
in appendix one the forecast outrun as
at quarter one is 10.46 million
which gives a small projected overspend
of 83 000
pounds this assumes full count full
application of the council's
covid uh grant allocation of just over 1
million
but does not yet assume any additional
payments
for loss of income under the
government's recently announced scheme
the covid19 pandemic is expected to have
a
significant impact on the council's
financial position
both in 2021 and in future years
although the full impact is not yet
clear and it will depend on how the
wider economy recovers
the council is currently incurring
additional unplanned expenditure
in a number of areas such as support for
our leisure services
provision for homeless services and
increased litter collection
it also expects to face losses across
most income lines
but most notably car parking
the projections within the report are
based on assumptions which have a high
degree
of uncertainty and therefore will be
subject to close monitoring
and refinement over the course of the
financial year
the council has so far received 1.011
million
of unring fence grant from central
government to contribute towards covid19
related pressures
it's required to report monthly on its
expected financial pressures relating
to the pandemic and these returns have
been shared with members
central government have also announced a
scheme to reimburse
local authorities for an element of its
lost income
details of the scheme were released
after this report was published
so it's not reflected in the financial
position that we're presenting at
quarter one
but a claim will be made in september
and the first
payment is expected in october
so it's effectively more of that later
the council will seek to mitigate any
remaining overspends
through in your savings as far as
possible but hazard
but we have reserves to draw down in the
last resort
no longer term covid related funding
beyond 2021 has yet been unannounced
but there is the strong possibility that
some loss of income and cost pressures
could be experienced and fell into the
20 20
into the year 21 22 and beyond
but it is difficult to have any
projection on those at this moment
in time the position will continue to be
closely monitored
over the financial year with assumptions
being updated
for budget setting as appropriate the
council is likely have to to have to
make some difficult decisions
to ensure its financial sustainability
in the immediate medium term
unless significant additional ongoing
resources are agreed
for local authorities in the budget
settlement
which is expected to be announced
following the comprehensive spending
review
in the late autumn of course as a
council
we do know that we don't stand alone in
the position we find ourselves in
the forecasted outrun of the council's
capital programme
as of quarter one is 1.923 million
the table at appendix 3 summarizes the
projection error the projected position
by service areas the major items with
slippage against the 2021 budget
are the place basis program which was
impacted by the covid pandemic
and the asset delivery program where
works are now likely to
be commenced in 21 22 in line with the
final business case agreed
by council in addition covert 19 has
delayed some works
funded by the disabled facilities grant
in the first quarter
the department are reviewing the policy
to enable additional households to
benefit from the grant
in line with the essex wide dfg disabled
facilities grant group
and government practice so i'm asking
the executive
to recommend to form council the
reprofiling
of 2.67 of the 2021 capital budget
into future years as is set out in
appendix 3
and to note the report if members have
any
questions of detail um we have naomi
lucas our section 151 officer on hand
to assist thank you chairman thank you
councillor smith
and do we have any questions please
i'm not seeing any hands at the moment
if there's no questions
can i just add that in this
extraordinary
year can i just add my thanks to
uh certainly you as portfolio holder
councillor smith but uh
principally also our officers who are
managing our finances extremely
effectively through
uh this as i say extraordinary time but
if there's no questions i will go to the
um
two recommendations and there are at
paragraph one
two uh recommendations the first one is
to note
the quarter one twenty twenty twenty one
revenue budget
and capital position set out in sections
three
and four and detailed in appendices
one to four and can i take that as being
noted no dude
thank you moving on to
the recommendation two and that is to
recommend to council
the pre-profiling of 2.67 million
on the planned 2020 21
capital program into future years as set
out
in appendix 3 and because this is a
recommendation
we need to do a vote which will be done
by a roll call of names
when sonia calls out your name please
indicate if you wish to have a recorded
vote
and then whether you are voting for or
against
the recommendation or if you wish to
abstain
sonia thank you um
councillor fd no recorded votes
and for the recommendation thank you
sonia
councillor mrs rowe thank you sonya
no and four please
councillor smith thank you uh no
recorded vote for the recommendation
council award no and for
sonia councillor webb
thank you sonya no and four please
counselor williams that's no and four
thank you sonia
and cancer wooden thank you sonya no
and four and i think that is a
unanimous um agreement
thank you members
okay we move now to agenda item
eight uh and for that item you will see
that that is uh
um in the pnc section so
we will need to exclude members of the
public
and the press members the following two
items on the agenda contain exempt
information
i will now move a recommendation that
under section 100
a in brackets 4 of the local government
act
1972 the public be excluded
from the meeting for the following item
of business on the grounds that it
involves the likely disclosure of exempt
information
as defined in paragraph three of part
one
of schedule 12a of the act do i have a
seconder for that
i'll take counselor ian ward
is that agreed members agreed agreed
agreed so there will now be a slight
pause while we switch off the uh
live streaming which uh sonia already
has